en terre un race les débats de la cour
d'assises dès mineurs se sont achevés
aujourd'hui débat sur les meurtres de
deux enfants commis en 1986 pour
lesquels patrick dils est rejugé les
parties civiles ont plaidé
mais ce que l'on retiendra venir et
ermites c'est que l'accusé eu beaucoup
de mal à s'expliquer sur ses premiers
voeux c'est vrai que patrick dils
clamant son innocence depuis maintenant
14 ans tout le monde s'attendait à ce
qu'il prenne la perche qui lui était
tendu pour s'expliquer sur ses aveux
très détaillé qui l'avait fait à
l'époque
de l'avis de tous les avocats y compris
des siens d'ailleurs pas très dils
n'aurait pas franchement su trouver les
mots pour convaincre répétant à
plusieurs reprises
je ne sais pas comment ni pourquoi j'ai
pu donner autant de détails alors que je
ne suis pas coupable
alors est ce que c'est un tournant dans
ce procès qui s'achèvera demain c'est
très difficile de répondre à cette
question claude parce que le huis clos
qui interdit aux journalistes d'assister
aux audiences nous empêche
définitivement d'évaluer l'impact ces
différents témoignages c'est qui est
plus que vraisemblable c'est que la
déposition de patrick dils aura été l'un
des moments clés de ce procès mais au
même titre sûrement que la déposition de
francis heaulme le tueur en série a nié
avoir tué des enfants mais il a reconnu
avoir été tout près du lieu du crime
n'arrivons pas à expliquer ce qu'il
avait pu faire ce jour là pour la
défense patrick dils et évidemment
innocent francis heaulme forcément
impliquer la démonstration n'a pas du
tout convaincu les parties civiles
réquisitoire et plaidoiries de la
défense demain avec un verdict très
attendu par dans la soirée merci